okay so yesterday Donald Trump's
convicted personal attorney Michael
Cohen testified before the House
Oversight Committee the day before
yesterday as I reported to you
congressman Matt Gaetz from Florida
obviously a Republican tweeted on the
eve of Michael Cohen's bombshell
testimony about Donald Trump implicating
him in multiple crimes an implicit
threat of blackmail to Michael Cohen
tweeting quote hey Michael Cohen do your
wife and father-in-law know about your
girlfriends maybe tonight meaning the
night before the testimony maybe tonight
would be a good time for that chat I
wonder if she'll remain faithful meeting
his wife when you're in prison she's
about to learn a lot and of course he
has since deleted the tweet after it
became apparent that there could be all
sorts of different crimes committed by
virtue of that tweet but we have it
anyway and as I pointed out on
yesterday's program he seems to have
violated federal law okay 18 USC
subsection 1512 B specifically prevents
or prohibits rather the tampering with
witnesses to official proceedings and we
made that case in detail yesterday and
my question as we wrapped up that
segment was are there going to be
investigations is the House Ethics
Committee going to investigate this is
the Justice Department going to
investigate this because it is the
apparent violation of federal law so far
the answers to all of those questions
are no but the good news is that the
Florida State Bar has opened up an
investigation into Matt gates over these
threats now you might say well hold on
the Florida Bar what does the Florida
Bar have to do with any of this was the
Florida Bar has to do with this is that
Matt Gaetz
is an attorney in Florida the state
which he represents in the House of
Representatives and so they are opening
up this investigation into gates now
they're not disclosing details right now
but we did get a statement from
spokesperson francine walker
who said that the bars quote quite aware
of Gates's comments and we have opened
an investigation the way
these investigations work is that the
attorney being investigated in this case
it's congressman gates have 15 days to
respond an investigation will be done
and potentially gates could end up
sanctioned by the Florida State Bar I
hope that they throw the book at him
here there should be a house ethics
investigation there should be a Justice
Department probe we may not ultimately
get them but this is at least something
and Matt Gaetz should be forced to
resign immediately here removal from
Congress should just be the beginning
but there is every reason to believe
just by a very straightforward reading
of the law that he has committed federal
crimes here he has attempted to
influence the testimony of Michael Cohen
either by influencing him to change what
he says to be less critical about Trump
is the obvious interpretation or maybe
to be scared out of testifying
altogether and we have rules to prevent
that from being done typically it's not
members of Congress that are doing the
tampering and the intimidation and
threatening blackmail but this is 2019
and Donald Trump is President of the
United States so that's the reality the
the sort of practical questions that you
have to look at in thinking about
whether this was a federal crime number
one is was the tweet a threat it pretty
clearly was a threat the idea is you had
better rethink testifying at all or what
you're going to say or I'm at gates I'm
going to tell your wife and
father-in-law about girlfriends that he
claims Michael Cohen has whether that's
true or not is is irrelevant but by any
sensible interpretation there was a
threat the second part is intent was the
intent of the tweet to be threatening
and that's where it can be more legally
difficult to the turn determined this is
sort of like when we talk about the
difficulty of getting convictions on
perjury just saying something that is
factually untrue is not enough to
demonstrate perjury and get a conviction
on perjury you do have to go towards the
intent to deceive and what the
individual knew at the time it's a sort
of similar thing here but
if you analyze the circumstances the
answer is pretty easy to find Matt Gaetz
new michael cohen was testifying
generally speaking he knew when the
testimony was scheduled to be and chose
to tweet the threat just hours before
that testimony he knew based on reports
that what cohen was going to be
testifying to would be potentially
damaging to the President of the United
States in fact implicating the President
of the United States in federal crimes
and context Matt Gaetz has a very long
history of doing Donald Trump's dirty
work on Twitter and the tweet was
directed at Michael Cohen it wasn't a
generic tweet it actually tagged Michael
Cohen so I think that in this particular
case you can make a very strong argument
that this indeed was a federal crime
good for the Florida Bar Association for
starting to investigate this but we need
a house ethics investigation we should
have a federal Justice Department
investigation I don't know if we will
but these are the exact folks that even
Republican voters should be repudiating
okay think back to my interview with
Rick Wilson Rick Wilson not someone who
I agree with politically but he
recognizes that Donald Trump is not a
conservative Republican in any sense of
that word over the last many many
decades he is something else and that if
you are just genuinely a principled
conservative in other words what you
care about our conservative principles I
disagree with you wholeheartedly I will
argue with you endlessly and tell you
that your views are wrong but you should
not be a supporter of Donald Trump's
because he doesn't align with those
conservative principles in any way it's
the Matt Gates's of the world and the
other endless unending sycophants that
are the ones that are exacerbating this
problem when actual principled
conservatives if they exist and I I hope
that some still do could actually be
working against the president as they
should be in alignment with their values
Matt Gaetz is not one of those guys he's
not going to be one of those guys and
hopefully eventually there will be
federal
charges against him for this make sure
you're following the show on Instagram
at David Pakman show
after the break I'm going to speak to
Kara Ellerby a professor at the
University of Delaware who argues if
we're trying to get actual gender
equality just adding women to places is
not actually going to achieve it she has
a really interesting perspective and
we're going to talk to her right after
this quick break one of today's sponsors
is privacy calm slash Pakman this is a
free service that I've actually been
using myself for a while now and I love
it you just take a few seconds to link
your debit card or bank account to
privacy coms mobile app or browser
extension for Firefox and Chrome and
what that does is allow you to instantly
create virtual credit cards that are
linked to your bank account so that
you're not actually putting your real
debit card number on the Internet and
you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below